hello
who are you
excuse me
you okay then
yeah she just came in okay who the [ __ ]
are you
janae
what are you doing here i've heard
really great reviews about all your
halloween parties yeah recommended by
nine out of ten [ __ ] but you know
what
not really my seat
okay maybe try that again but this time
lose an attitude and tell me the truth
i invited her
jake before her little number at school
i i know she was gonna come what
what are you wearing
i i was just trying it on you said that
maybe we could do my idea yeah sure if
you want to turn this into a who wore a
best [ __ ] show that's obviously not what
i want right like you have never ever
made me feel like a fool addie i mean
where would i have gotten the idea that
you would try to humiliate me in public
hmm
maybe by cheating on me
it's just a costume
all right fine have fun with your new
friend
addie
how do you like them pancakes huh
she's not my friend
she's not welcome here
versus right
oh
stupid [ __ ] you can have her bro
wow
my ex was a pitcher
i guess i gained some muscle at batting
practice
i'm sure he's very proud of you
he's a bit of a jerk but
he was right
i don't need him
well you need some ice for that
hand good job come on
all right do you want the good news
first or the bad news whatever's faster
okay the good news is whatever's in here
is important because this lock is the
[ __ ] right the bad news is this lock is
the [ __ ]
i swear someone make sure you're fine
well it's kind of a
weird feeling but it was worth it
take this
did you see the look on his face
stop talking get out well that's just
[ __ ] awesome
[Music]
hey
dave i'm i'm so sorry i i am done with
those losers i swear
it's okay you don't have to listen to me
i want to
money costume is much cuter
i'll go change
only if you want to
[Music]
you